whether they're psychotic stalkers or
pompous jerks or just terrible
decision-makers significant others in
scary movies tend to cause a lot more
problems than they saw
let's take a look at the horror movie
boyfriends who were the absolute worst
there's obsessed and then there's David
McCall and beer were unfortunately
introduced to David and he's any
father's worst nightmare right from the
start it takes him almost no time to
start developing an unhealthy
infatuation with our leading lady the
teenaged Nicole and bucking any attempts
by her dad to keep him away from her
little by little David starts to reveal
how unhinged and violent he is arming
everyone from Nicole's best friend to a
security guard to the poor family dog
despite all that he does to her loved
ones though he still somehow believes
that he and Nicole have a future
together
plus he considers his lethal home
invasion plot to be a grand gesture that
will lead to a reunion he's dangerous
and deranged and completely clueless
about what women want in other words the
full package the idea of a high school
teacher engaging in an affair with a
students even if the student has passed
the age of consent is upsetting under
any circumstance high school years are
so formative and devoid of responsible
decision-making that it's inherently
dangerous and predatory for teachers to
have any personal relationship with
students so the boy next door's Claire
definitely deserves some score and for
sleeping with Noah considering that he's
her next-door neighbor her son's friend
and a student at her school but after
she decides to call it quits as the
result of the guilt and shame she feels
about it
his overreaction is intense Noah starts
trying to win her back by vandalizing
the school wall with a lewd message
about their fling and blackmailing her
with pictures and a video of their tryst
when that doesn't work he starts making
threats to her family and all of this
comes with the explicit caveat that his
aggression will only end if she
continues being his girlfriend no
definitely does not mean no for this guy
[Music]
with me
for you dye was technically hue AKA jeff
redmond isn't a horror movie boyfriend
but he is a horror movie hookup gone
horribly wrong in it follows you takes j
out on a date first to the theater and
then to have a quick drink ultimately he
manages to convince j that he's an
ordinary guy with no ulterior motive and
the to wind up hooking up in the back of
his car once the deed is done
Hugh reveals the true motive hers
interest in advances he's passing on to
her a terrifying supernatural entity in
the hopes that she'll pass it along to
someone else
etc until Hugh is so far removed from
the chain that he can live a long and
worryfree life the whole movie is a
thinly veiled metaphor for the real-life
threat of STDs so Hugh's decision to
condemn Jay to a probable death just to
save his own skin is both indefensible
and one heck of a cinematic case for
abstinence to be fair to paranormal
activities Myka he really did have a
point when he said that Katie should
have given him some kind of heads-up
about her family's ghost curse before
she moved in with him that still doesn't
excuse some of the stupid and unhelpful
things he does once a vengeful spirit
begins wreaking havoc on their home for
one thing he has an annoyingly
relentless obsession with taping
everything but at least that sets up a
convenient plot device to help frame the
film and its signature found footage
style the real problem with Mika is that
he decides it's a grand idea to taunt
the demon that's been haunting them then
he ignores Katie's wishes by borrowing a
Ouija board and of course all hell then
literally breaks loose it's one thing
that he goes all Blair Witch Project on
everything but it's quite another when
he starts actively inviting trouble from
the mad poltergeist no you haven't been
having any progress and you're not in
control it is in control and if you
think you're in control then you're
being in has helped does a creepy
internet stalker who pays a girl to
flirt actually qualify as a boyfriend
the jury's still out on that one
but tinker is about as close as it gets
in camp he seems to genuinely care about
Alice calling her directly on a regular
basis to chitchat about her off-camera
life and showering her with tips and
compliments he even moves to her
hometown to try and win her over in real
life when the going gets tough though
and tinker finds out that his favorite
cam girl
speed has been taken over by a
computerized cloned version of her he
fails spectacularly to intervene or even
care very much instead of helping Alice
in her hour of need
he sneaks off to chat with the
impersonator who's making her life so
hellish because all he really cares
about is looking at Alice online in any
form it's bad enough that he takes the
digital adult entertainment game way too
seriously but when he betrays Alice
that's when he becomes truly
disconnected from the beginning of
scream it's clear that there's something
not quite right with ski Ulrich's Billy
Loomis with his shaggy hair smoldering
expressions and sense of entitlement he
doesn't do much to hide the fact that
he's a generic dirtbag throughout the
whole movie what we don't find out until
the end though is just how thoroughly
depraved he really is after successfully
luring Sidney to give up her virginity
to him
Billy's free to then let his
partner-in-crime stood take her out it
doesn't work and she eventually finds
out that the two of them are responsible
for all those phone calls and
cat-and-mouse games Billy and Stu's say
it's all just revenge for Sydney's
mother breaking up the Loomis parents
marriage and that they're just emulating
scary movies with their approach still
there's something particularly sinister
- Billy turning his relationship with
Sydney into a bedroom conquest that must
be completed before the killing can
begin on top of being a psycho killer
he's also a sleaze
what's the matter Sydney you look like
you've seen a ghost there's no doubt
that the most abusive relationship Sarah
has in the craft is with Nancy and the
pair of selfish sidekicks who enabler
however Ulrich's Chris hooker is a
classic case of creepy as well instead
of trying to pursue a legitimate
relationship with Sarah he decides to go
and sully her reputation before she's
even had a chance to establish one at
her new school he does this by telling
everyone that he's already slept with
her just to make himself look all big
and bro-tastic chris is eventually put
under a love spell by Nancy's coven so
he might not be to blame for every
single one of his acts of desperation
but the curse probably only elevates
behaviors that he's already capable of
so when he later tries to force himself
on Sarah
after she refuses to sleep with him that
is certainly still him being an
inappropriate scumbag cursed or not
Carter Duncan might be what the titles
referring to in the perfect guy but he
is anything but at first he seems
completely handsome and charming and
exactly what Leah needs to get over her
breakup with her ex-boyfriend Dave but
when a simple encounter at a gas station
with a stranger turns into a full-on
attack from her new lover his true
personality reveals itself he's not warm
at all instead he's vicious and
impetuous and dangerous breaking up is
hard to do even under the best of
circumstances but when a guy has as many
screws loose as Carter it's practically
impossible
Leigha ends up having to recruit or ex
to protect her from Carter as he stalks
her at work sneaks into her home and
even steals her cat and that's the tame
stuff eventually things turned violent
and Leah must take matters into her own
hands to prevent him from doing this
all again to hurt or other unsuspecting
women if you thought your last tinder
date was terrible this guy could make
anyone look like swipe right potential
by comparison it's hard to know what
possessed Jenna to ever date Trent in
the first place and the Friday the 13th
reboot but a lot of slasher movies don't
exactly work if the characters actually
use logic and make good choices Trent is
spoiled and arrogant and only invites
his friends to his parents lake house to
show off how wealthy he and his family
are Trent is also completely unkind he
even starts an argument with a guy who's
only out searching for his missing
sister on top of all those terrible
personality traits he's also a cheater
of the worst order as soon as Jenna
steps away from the lake house to do a
good deed he hooks up with her best
friend and their love scene is cringy
enough to make anyone wonder why Jenna
gives him the time of day when he says
about female anatomy will make you laugh
and cry all at once beauty is only
skin-deep but this one that's for sure
to be fair to the Flies Seth Brundle it
isn't necessarily his fault that he's
being slowly morphed into the brundlefly
but that doesn't mean anyone would want
to put up with him once the side effects
start kicking in even before he merges
DNA with a horsefly
Seth is a bit questionable as boyfriend
material not only is he odd he's also a
bit possessive of his journalist
girlfriend Ronny
but Seth becomes most unpleasant after
his little teleportation experiment goes
so wrong he becomes aggressive and
eventually loses all trace of empathy
and emotion instead of protecting Ronnie
from the danger he poses to her he tries
to force her to carry his baby to term
and even attempts to fuse all three of
them together into one entity it's bad
enough that he gets himself into this
mess by being so sloppy with his
workstation but the fact that he wants
to drag his girlfriend an unborn child
down with him makes Seth and especially
bug and boyfriend what's it gotta do
when the woman he loves is suddenly
turned into a Deadite by an ancient evil
force that's been awoken by a weird book
for ash Williams and Evil Dead the
answer is to decapitate Linda
and then slicer still animated body into
bits what a catch never mind the fact
that this is all his fault
as he's the one who brought out the
Necronomicon and tape reading that set
all the Hellfire in motion in the first
place even if we forgive that
it's his next action that proves he's
completely unable for ever the 2000
video game Evil Dead hail to the king
continues the Ash action and shows him
dating a poor girl named Jenny whom he
convinces to go to the same cabin where
all of the crazy and terrible things
happened before were later told she died
in an accident with a bus but that's a
little too convenient to be true isn't
it
any time a guy has an alter ego called
bad ash it ain't good news check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite films are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]